From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
This is David Cline for the Smithsonian African American History and Culture Museum and the Library of Congress, Civil Rights History Project.
Today is Saturday, March 2, 2013, and I am in the City of San Francisco, California with Reverend Dr. Amos C. Brown.
Good afternoon. Good afternoon. So thank you so much for joining us and sharing your story.
My pleasure and great privilege to share with you.
And I am on channel 2 and Reverend Brown is on channel 1.
Okay, no, I got it all covered. Okay, I can get into it.
So Reverend Brown, if we could just start, if you could tell us a little bit about where you were born and your family, your people,
and how that informed you at growing up as a young person.
I was born in Jackson, Mississippi, February 20, 1941, and according to the U.S. Census, my great-great-grandfather, Patrick Brown,
was born and slave in Franklin County, Mississippi, in a community called Hamburg, East of Natchez.
And that area was one great dropping off point for slaves from about 1820 to 1850, and 4550.
In fact, there was a terrific cholera epidemic around 1830 in Natchez, and these slaves who shipped down the river were quarantined out of a place called Forks of the Road, and that's East of Natchez.
So it was from that area that my great-great-grandfather was a slave.
And I have had that sense of history when I had the occasion of my aunt, my father's sister, sharing this information with me.
Naturally, I was born in a segregated apartheid, south, and Mississippi when things were really difficult.
In fact, it was commonplace for me to hear of the tales of legends, of Blacks being mysteriously unaccounted for in the Mississippi Delta, where my father passed a rule of churches.
In fact, my father succeeded Reverend George Lee in Holmes County, Mississippi, in a Baptist church.
Reverend George Lee was murdered in 1955, Mother's Day, the same year that Emmett Till was murdered.
[Emmett Till's] body was found on August 28, 1955.
And I remember the instance in which a man named Eddie Noel, a sharp shooter who confronted white man for having a affair with his wife, went to this honkettonk and restaurant in Holmes County, Mississippi,
to tell his wife that she had to come home and not work there anymore.
And when this white man jumped him and beat him up, this 28-year-old man, World War II veteran, went to his car, came back with his 22 rifle, and shot this white man dead with that 22 rifle.
He fled from the scene with his wife, and for 18 days he was on the run at about three to 400 white men.
The shaman would drop from moonshine liquor. This posse tried to apprehend him. They couldn't find him.
But it was a woman named Arenia Mallory, who was the first principal of the Saints Industrial School in Lexington, Mississippi.
That was a school, it was started as a high school, sponsored by the Church of God in Christ.
Church of God in Christ was founded by Bishop Charles Harrison Mason at the turn of the last century, about 19, about 1906, after he had gone down to Los Angeles to witness the Azusa Street Revival.
My point being, by giving all this background history is that this woman was so influential.
It was a vice president of the National Council of Negro Women, that group that was founded by the great woman Mary McLeod Bethune.
Dr. Mallory went to Eddie Noel and convinced him that he should turn himself in.
But before she met with him, she learned that he had killed two other deputies, shares.
And that meant that this black man murdered three white men and was on the run and did not turn himself in until this black woman convinced him to give up.
Long short of it is that when he went to court, the judge, I'm sure in his mind, felt that in an Negro who would kill three white men in Mississippi, must have been crazy.
So he had an order for him to be examined over at the Whitfield Mental Institution.
And the record is that he was never tried and convicted.
He was released later and it was found out that he was a descendant, a child of one of the governors of Mississippi.
From 1909 to 1913, Governor (Edmund) Noel.
And I don't know if they had anything to do with his getting off, but he was never said to try and convicted.
He died a natural death in Fort Wayne, Indiana.
But I remember the child, the excitement, the serial reports of Eddie Noel killing these white men.
And what would happen if they called him?
Had to react to that.
Well, that story definitely was a great interest to me as a child.
And another story that impacted me was the murder of Emmett Till, both happening around the same time.
And then...
And you would have been about 11 at that time.
And here is the boy not much older than you.
Yes.
And so how did you react to that story?
I did. I reacted to those stories.
My son is a school teacher, Miss Eserrandel, who was treasurer of the Jackson branch of NAACP over 30 years.
One Sunday morning at the Farish Street Baptist Church, which was one of the few churches that opened this door to end a civil rights activity.
What's the name of it again?
Farish, F-A-R-I-S-H. Farish Street Baptist Church.
Once on the morning she asked me, did I know what my name meant?
I was eight years old then.
And I told her, no.
She said, your name means Amos.
That's a Hebrew word.
And it means the prophet who bears the burdens of the people.
And I never forgot that.
So that when I became aware of Edenore, I became aware of the liching of Emmett Till, Reverend George Lee.
And when I became aware of a meeting that was held in Dallas, Texas in 1954, that my sister attended along with Medgar Evers.
It was at that meeting in 1954 that Channing H. Tobias, who was chairman of the board of NAACP, Corn the Frees, freed by 1963.
And when Gloria came back from that meeting with Medgar Evers, and I heard her telling what happened, I was all intrigued about this conversation that I had with her.
And she said, you know, in 1963, there would be no more segregation.
We'll be able to vote.
We'll have to sit in the back of the bus.
But we're going to have to work to make sure that it really happens.
And I was excited about this change that was going to come because of what this man said in Dallas.
That I got involved and I organized the first Youth Council of NAACP in 1955.
And after I organized that Youth Council, that spring of 1956, Medgar Evers asked my mother if I could travel with him to San Francisco,
to the National Convention of NAACP, where I would have exposure with other young people from across the country, who were in civil rights activity under the umbrella of NAACP Youth Movement.
That was my first time out of West.
Medgar Evers had just bought an old 1955 Oldsmobile. We called it the Blue Goose.
It didn't have air condition in that day.
In fact, you had to use ice packs, bags of ice to put on the hood of the car to cool the engine as you went through the desert coming westward.
So that summer of 1956, the month of July, we came to San Francisco.
And never ever get when we approached that bay bridge and I saw all of this water after we had come up through the valley, you know, up San Francisco.
And I came to this great meeting.
I didn't have money to stay in hotels. I stayed with a family who were friends of my mother.
And her name was Hutchison. They lived up on Fulton Street, up near Fulton and the Visitora.
And I walked from Fulton and the Visitora every day to the meetings, to the night-lip hell mass meetings.
And it was my fortune to first hear Martin Luther King on youth night.
He had just won the victory in Montgomery.
And when he gave his panoramic treatment of history and I was talking about the times of the Greeks and Egyptians and all that good stuff.
And he said, but this is the greatest time for me and for all of us to be alive.
And he spoke about the hope that he had for America and the eradication of racism.
I never shall forget. He ended that great speech that night by saying, I have the dream that the day will come when all of God's children from base black to troubled white will be significant on the Constitution's keyboard.
And I have a copy of that speech in my possession now that I heard him deliver.
And on that Sunday morning of the Convention, believe it or not, I worship at this church.
I came back to be pastor of Dr. Dr. Leon Howard Sullivan.
And the name of this church is just...
Third Baptist Church, which is the oldest predominant African-American Baptist Church in Western United States.
And it was founded in August, August the 1st of 1852, which was the centennial of the abolition of slavery in the Caribbean Islands.
So this church also had a great conference with history.
That's the same year that Harriet Beecher Stowe's book, Uncle Tom's Cabin, was published.
And I'm confident that there was agitation in there, a move for self-determination on part of blacks before the Civil War here in the West.
And that's why Eliza Davis [and her] husband William and others moved out of white first Baptist, white first Baptist was founded in 1849.
They moved out because they met discrimination in the church.
And they decided that they wanted to worship God indignate and not in immatilation.
And I've been pastor of this church since 1976.
Now, how did I get here? I had some intermittent stops.
What was it?
Well, it was a good one.
And your father was a pastor.
And I'm wondering if you could talk a little bit about being raised in that family earlier before when we were talking about books on your father's bookshelves.
And I'm wondering if you could talk about how your family talked with you about race or race consciousness or involvement in movement to better the place of African-Americans.
Actually, I had very little conversation with my father.
Because he was very busy. He was a country-attentive preacher.
And he worked as a janitor.
He was aware of the movement.
He was definitely aware of discrimination.
But in terms of his telling me, you must get involved and do this. He didn't operate that way.
It was of my charge and because of my exposure to people like Megavars, John W. Dixon, who was superintendent of the Sunday School and Farish Street Baptist Church there in Jackson.
Miss Essie Collins, as I mentioned earlier, who was the treasurer of the Jackson branch.
Miss Mary Cox, who wrote insurance, never wrote a bus.
She walked every place she went because she said she would not ride any bus in segregated emulation.
And Carsie Hall, a letter carrier, and was an attorney.
Went to night school and came an attorney.
Samuel Bailey was the advisor of our youth council.
He was a member of the College of Baptist Church. Let me say parenthetically.
Back in the day, there were only about three or four churches that embraced the civilized movement.
The other pastors and churches were a theologically conservative and didn't want to become involved.
They were only concerned about the saving of souls and getting people ready for heaven.
However, there were these churches, Farish Street, that I was reared in, baptized there by Reverend Chester Arthur Greer from Fort Worth, Texas.
There was Pearl Street African Methodist Episcopal Church, passed by Reverend Gerr Horton.
There was College Hill Baptist Church, passed by Reverend W. L. Jones.
And later, the new Mount Zion Baptist Church, that Reverend Bale became pastor of during the height of the student demonstrations of the 60s.
Those were all the churches who would open their doors.
Out of how many in Jackson?
Oh my God. You must have had about 100 more churches. People were afraid.
We were mavericks. And literally, I know also that the State Sovereignty Commission, that watch the spying group on all civil rights workers, had a 10-page file on me.
When that file was open in the 1980s.
We knew that we were being watched, but we didn't think that they were that serious in terms of spending money to spy on teenagers, kids, but even had a report in that file.
Now, I will give you a copy of it.
In which it was reported that I had opened a bank account at the deposit guaranteed bank.
One of the vice presidents broke the law, broke confidentiality, and reported to Mayor Thompson and to the chief of police that I had opened this bank account.
And the amount of money that we deposited.
And there was a notation there that this name must be kept confidential and they had blotted out the name.
His name was LATAM.
LATAM. I don't know if he's still alive or not, but he was a vice president of the deposit guaranteed bank of Jackson.
They also had on file that any place that I spoke as president of the youth council has later state president of youth councils in Mississippi.
Any conventions that I went to, in fact, it was in 1958, again with Mr. Evers and Mr. Joseph Broadwater, who was a member of our branch.
We went to the convention in Cleveland.
That was the year that the Little Rock Nine won the Nobel Peace Prize.
And I was in an interview with the Cleveland Plain Dealer paper about conditions of blacks in Mississippi and the double system of education we had.
And the fact that black teachers were not receiving salaries equal to whites.
And someone, I can give you a cup of that, dog.
Someone sent to the white superintendent, Mr. Kirby Walker, Kirby P. Walker.
That article.
And I was told when I got back home in the school that fall going into my senior year in 1959 at Jim Hill High School, that segregated school.
I was told by my principal, Mr. Luther Marshall, that he had gotten orders from the white superintendent and the black superintendent of schools that I was to not be permitted to re-enroll and Jim Hill High School.
I was told to keep my mouth shut and I was creating too much trouble.
Well, when Medgar Evers again, my mentor heard about this, he got with my mother and later contacted my father, who was, by the way, at the National Baptist Convention,
in September when school opened up.
And we threatened to follow a lawsuit for the deterioration of, of Provine High School school.
That's a white high school that near my home.
And all of this is written up in Medgar Evers' biography, that book by Man in Marvel's and the biography.
It was autobiography, excuse me, of Medgar Evers?
Well, all of this is documented in that book.
And when Medgar Evers threatened the suit, they really started moving in.
They didn't want to integrate the schools.
And so they rescinded my being prohibited from going to Jim Hill.
They let me back in.
But they abolished the student council that I was also president of in order to break my influence.
I have a, the students later elected me president of the senior class.
Well, they would help my holding their position.
And I was valedictorian.
But again, to break my spirit, they denied me that honor.
And only let me be salutatorian.
Now, what's your principle?
What's, what's, what's, where these his decisions or what's he being told to?
He's been told, in fact, years later, after I had gone, finished more house,
crows of seminary, I had become an accomplished pastor.
I went back home and he saw me and he broke down and started crying.
He said to me, Brown, you were a kid then.
And you didn't understand that we were on a lot of pressure, on a lot of threats.
And we were afraid of losing our jobs.
He said, I don't mean interpersonal harm against you.
He said, but I had to do what the people told me to do.
And it was that kind of an atmosphere, and Mr. Simpich back there.
In fact, in that state's Obnacomission report, there was an indication of how they had spies
who would go to any mass meeting and would take down the license plate numbers
of anybody's car who was parked around the church.
And they would find out who the car belonged to.
And the next week, they would research where you work and you would get a notice
that you would fire for being involved with civil rights activity.
I continued my involvement in the NAACP Youth Movement and was elected National Chairman
of the Youth Work Committee in 1959 in New York City.
Again, Dr. King was at that meeting.
And it was there that Pitcher was taken of Roy Wilkins, the then Executive Secretary
and Dr. King and myself as Chairman of the National Youth Work Committee.
And it was that meeting that I presided over the report things of all youth units in the nation.
And I was privileged to receive the report from Clara Luper, who was the advisor of Oklahoma City Youth Council
and Bob Rapose, who was the president of the Youth Council in Oklahoma City.
These two personages reported on their successes in Oklahoma City.
Again, that magic number August 28th, August 28th, 1958, was when there was the first sit-down movement
in an organized mass way by young blacks on the umbrella of NAACP.
You see, in this country, we have romanticized the student city movement.
The student city movement did not begin in Greensboro, 1960.
It started in Oklahoma City, August 28th, 1958.
And at that meeting, back to my point about my presiding in New York, in 1959,
according to the report of the credentials committee of the NAACP that's on record at the Library of Congress,
there was a young man named Ezell Blair Jr, who was an alternate youth-gut delegate to the convention.
He heard Bob Rapose, Clara Luper, reporting about what they had done in Oklahoma City.
And when he went back to Greensboro, that fall of 1959 entering as a freshman at A&T College,
he started telling his fellow classmates about this movement.
And no one would move with him during the fall, but he got three others to go with him and sit down on February of the first, 1960.
And then the movement began to spread like wildfire across the South, to Nashville, to Tallahassee, to Baton Rouge, to Atlanta.
And that's the real acquistor.
I'm working now to write a book entitled Before 1960.
To put it all an accurate historical perspective of when, what was then called, the student sit down,
it was called sit-in, it was called sit-down movement.
And this movement of 1958, it was also replicated in which starcansers, Louis Vigatucche, all youth units of NAACP.
And we had laid, by the way, the groundwork for this, here in San Francisco in 1956, on the leadership of Herbert Wright, who was then the National Youth Secretary.
He's still alive, he lives up in Connecticut.
He was reared in the Houston, Texas branch.
And he got us engaged in student youth activism.
And this was written up in the Tokyo Times, the London Times, the New York Times,
all the major papers around the world. But the American press sat on what happened and tried to wipe it out.
Forget about it, in 1958.
I think it's such an important part of the story is that NAACP youth training that the Greensboro guys had,
also that, you know, that Rosa Parks was the training that Rosa Parks had.
People get that story.
His thing about Duke, this park worked as a secretary of the Montgomery NAACP.
And she was advisor to the Youth Council.
Now, he was a connection that brought me into the loop.
I met Dr. King here in San Francisco in 1956.
There was a year of the victory of the Montgomery movement.
There were delgas from the Montgomery branch.
But what happened? In 1956, the state of Alabama sought to wipe out NAACP's
and they made it illegal for NAACP to function in Alabama.
And that's why Dr. King and others had to organize the Southern Christian Leadership Conference.
So they went under the umbrella of the Faith Community.
They were smart enough to say, if you won't let us function as a civil rights advocacy organization in Alabama,
you can't mess with our churches and our religion.
That's exactly how the Southern Christian Leadership Conference came into being.
But back to your point about Rosa Parks, her being involved was started on the umbrella of NAACP
and serving as an advisor to the Youth Council in Montgomery, Alabama.
Just a quick pause.
Could you tell us how you first got to know Medgar Evers and developed this relationship with him?
As I lose you earlier, I became aware of who he was through my sister Gloria Holiday, who's still living.
She lives in Denver, Colorado.
And Medgar Evers was a very humble, warm, engaging man.
And we discovered my interest, my talents, my ability, even as a lad.
He encouraged me.
He sort of was my surrogate father, elder brother.
And he made sure that I had opportunities to go to meetings wherever they were.
And my mother, who was President responsible for me, because my father's, I said, travel a lot.
But she never questioned Medgar Evers.
She never expressed it. She did have any fear.
She never expressed it.
She would always say, well, if that's what you want to do, go ahead.
I'm with you.
And Medgar Evers took me to all these meetings.
We even went up to the Mississippi Delta.
And there were points when we disguised ourselves as sharecroppers to hold mass meetings,
or to investigate cases.
And we were all over the state.
You mentioned fear.
Did you experience fear in situations like that?
Not really.
I guess I was too young, maybe too daring, too naive.
I wasn't scared at all.
But as I looked back on what I know about what the State Cyber and Commission was doing,
my life was really in harm's way.
The State Cyber and Commission in that file that I mentioned,
gave a summation report after they had all these details over.
And a documentation of what I had done.
Amos Brown is a full-fledged agitator.
And this is the report on him that we must keep active.
Wherever I was arrested, they had a record of that,
whether it was in Atlanta, Savannah, Georgia.
I let away the end of the time and beach there.
Also, I desegregated first Baptist Church of Atlanta.
Dr. Benjamin Mays wrote about that in his writings.
At church, there's now passed by Reverend Charles Stanley.
Back in 1961, did not admit black people there.
In fact, that's where I met my wife.
She was a student at Spellman.
The white students at Georgia Tech,
more-how students, led a kneel-in rather kneel-in once on the morning.
And at that church, Deacons and Trustees literally picked up these students
and threw them out of that church.
And after the service was over, I showed my wife outside on the steps
with a number of other wives to be there.
It is a number of other students at Spellman.
So every kind of demonstration to break down barriers, I was part of it.
And you were a more-how student than your graduate from high school.
Yeah.
I was a part of the leadership contingency of the Senate movement
in Atlanta, along with Marian Wright,
Edelman, who now is over the Children's Defense Fund.
In fact, she wrote a book entitled Lanterns.
And in that book is a chapter where she mentions me.
She said there was a young, bright, in ACP,
a name Amos Brown in the room,
when we met with the college presidents to let them know
that we were going to sit in.
You see, when we decided to get them out in the movement,
all of the college presidents of those black schools called us in,
because they knew we were going to join with other students throughout the South.
And they said, we're not going to try and discourage you
or block your activity.
But you ought to let the world know why you're doing what you're doing.
And it was Dr. Rufus Clement and Dr. Mays who suggested
that we would write a document explaining why I raised in that term,
but what we were doing.
And they said, we will raise the money to pay for your document
to be published in the Atlanta Journal Constitution.
And I was a part of that committee.
I was the youngest one in the room.
The other persons in the room were Lonnie King, who still alive.
Charles Black, who still alive.
Herschelle Sullivan, Julian Bond,
and Mary and Wright Elliman,
it's Don Klaug, who's a Klaug, A.U.
among others. We went in that room.
And after we wrote that document,
it's entitled the Committee on Appeal for Human Rights.
And it was published in the Journal.
We sat in, and I spent time in jail with Dr. Martin Luther King,
his brother, A.D. (King), Otis Moss, still alive,
past the Maritus of the Oliver Baptist Church of Cleveland,
Ohio, and Lonnie King, and David Satcher.
David Satcher, the former Surgeon General of the United States.
We were schoolmates at Moor House.
Like we lived in the same dorm, our junior year, May is home.
We entered the Moor House at the same time too.
So that was my experience.
But my experience was not just relegated to civil rights in America.
I became aware of world affairs.
In 1957, when I met Rajmohan Gandhi,
Mahatma Gandhi's grandson, he was here in the United States
with an organization called Moral Rearmament.
It was founded by Frank Buchman in England.
It's called the Oxford Movement back in the 40s.
And they had the, what I consider to be a bit naive,
that the world would be made better if people just commit themselves
to some absolutes, absolute honesty, absolute purity.
I absolutely non-sabious at all this.
Well, I listened to it, and I saw some good in it.
But I felt back then that you needed some realistic, legislative action
to change the legal underpinnings for discrimination in this country.
In addition to calling on the individual to change one's heart
and try to live a higher standard of living.
And later, after I went to that world affairs camp meeting
up at Mackinac Island, Michigan, Mr. Gandhi invited me to be his guest.
And there were about 87 countries reputed from around the world.
That was the same year that Martin Luther King won the Spingarn Medal,
which is the highest medal that could be bestowed on an African-American
for achievement in previous years in that particular calendar year.
And Mr. Gandhi was there to be a part of that ceremony.
And then from that international exposure, I also was invited in 1958
by the Quakers to attend a world affairs camp at Camp Danby near Cornell University.
It's been a whole summer there.
Here I was, kid out of Mississippi.
My parents went there from a fluent.
Although we were poor in things, we were rich in ideas and academic pursuits
and commitment to social engineering and social justice.
So that's been basically my career.
And since then, this has been my passion.
I was given a scholarship when I finished Morehouse in 1964 to go to Africa.
That was my first trip to Africa.
1950.
1964.
Yeah.
So that was the year that I finished Morehouse and also my year of being admitted
to Crozer Theological Seminary for my Theological Training.
And by the way, one of my letters, the recommendations, was written by Dr. King.
He actually studied with Dr. King at Morehouse.
Yes, I did.
But when I went to graduate school, he wrote one of my letters of recommendation.
He went to Crozer Theological Seminary back in 1948.
I have a picture of him at the Calvary Baptist Church with the Church Officers
when he was 19 years old when he entered Crow's.
See, his father was a very close friend of Dr. J. Pius Barber.
Dr. Barber was editor of the National Baptist Voice, a graduate of Morehouse,
native of Galveston, Texas.
His father was a preacher there in Galveston, too.
And he finished Morehouse around 1911.
And he went to Crozer Theological Seminary.
As a second black student to finish there.
And from the time that he finished, he was the unofficial dean of all black students at Crozer Theological Seminary.
And we spent many nights in his Paula discussing politics, theology, you name it.
And he was a mentor for many great preachers who were of the prophetic, liberal tradition.
So, his William Augustus Jones from Kentucky, he's now deceased.
He was passed to that great church in Brooklyn, New York, Bethany Baptist.
Dr. Samuel D. Proctor, who went to Crow's.
Dr. Harold Carter, who still alive, is in Baltimore, Maryland.
Dr. B. J. Whipper, Shr. Malabama.
Dr. Charles Booth, is in Columbus, Ohio.
Dr. Jesse Wendell Mapson, is passed in Philadelphia.
Reverend Dr. Archie LeMone, who served with the World Council of Churches in Geneva, Switzerland.
When his having finished Seminary and this tradition is what created African-American preachers' prophets who own the cutting edge and never bifurcated the gospel.
There was never either a personal celebration or social celebration.
It was always both and.
We could not see at all how one could talk about saving a soul and not dealing with the society that made it difficult for the soul to be armable just and fair.
We did not get a deal with both.
That is why we got the blessing and the gift of Mordecai Wyatt Johnson.
He too finished Morehouse College.
And went to Colgate Rochester, the sister school of Crozer Theological Seminary.
Dr. Mordecai Wyatt Johnson, born in Paris, Tennessee.
He studied at Harvard, University of Chicago.
But he was pastor of the first Baptist Church in Charleston, West Virginia in 1926.
Before 1926, the Board of Trustees did not have a confidence in any black who could be president of that school.
But they decided that they were giving out an opportunity.
And when they sent out the search committee, people like Ralph Bunche, Sterling Brown and others, they felt that they were scholars and they should have been considered.
But the prevailing wisdom was that they needed a personality like Dr. Mordecai Wyatt Johnson to lead that school and take it to its next level.
He was elected president in 1926.
When he got there, his first agenda item was to discover what could be done to bring that law school to first class status.
It was a night school when he got there.
What did he do? He called on Justice Louis Brandeis, who served on the Supreme Court.
And he asked him, if you were to build a first class law school, what would you advise the builder to do?
And on the condition that Justice, that Mr. Reverend Dr. Johnson would not tell him what he said until he died, he told him,
I would build a law school that would teach young black lawyers how to become corporate lawyers to make money for them, say, a criminal lawyer.
He said, I would build a great school that would teach young black minds how to master the art of constitutional law.
And from that conversation, Dr. Johnson sought out Charles Hamilton Houston and gave him the green light to build a law school, making first class.
And then Charles Hamilton Houston's first class.
There were three young men, Thurgood Marshall from Baltimore, Maryland, who had been denied admission to the University of Maryland law school.
Oliver Hill from Richmond, Virginia, Robert Carter from Montclair, New Jersey.
And there was the council and the mentorship of one James Nabrit.
It was that team that went before the Supreme Court, beginning in 1953, got involved in developing the briefs.
And they went and argued so persuasively against the backdrop and the buttress of the 14th Amendment, equal protection on the law, making the case
that segregated public education was not equal and they denied it, denied black children equal protection on the law.
That amendment brought us over and broke down the legal barriers for discrimination in this country, reverse, Plessy v. Ferguson.
So we owe it to Dr. Johnson, the foundation of the black church, for all that we have achieved, not the total church, because not everybody was involved in the movement.
In fact, the joint center for political studies came out with reports some time ago, not only about 3% of the black preachers were involved in civil rights movement.
It's a romanticized statement to say that everybody was with Dr. King. They were not.
For as I mentioned to you earlier, there were about three or four churches in my own town of Jackson, Mississippi, who became in the movement.
And Dr. King was a remnant of this group.
He was a new breed, just a handful.
And then Florida, there was CK Steel in Tallahassee.
And my aunt and father Gibson, in Tampa, alien Laurie.
And of course Tennessee, you had Benjamin Lawson Hooks.
And Dr. Ones and Metropolitan.
In Georgia, you had Samuel Woodrow Williams, who was college minister.
And he co-team taught that course, that seminar in social philosophy with Dr. King that I mentioned earlier.
And his college minister at Morehouse, and was pastor of the oldest black Baptist church in Atlanta, friendship Baptist.
Can you talk a little bit more about that class that you were in with them?
Oh, that was an exciting class.
It was small, only eight of us.
And Dr. King was very down to earth.
There was nothing arrogant about him.
He was a regular brother.
He was a brilliant man.
And it was just an incredible experience to see it at his feet.
And one thing I remember about that class is he was talking about the theory of personalism.
The he acquired from Brightman at Boston University, when he was studying his Ph.D. degree, where he got his Ph.D.,
We all know in systematic theology.
Personalism that every human being is immune with dignity and worth.
And we should respect that worth and dignity.
And not in rate, not in measure of judge people on the basis of where I was born, where I was one's color, what one religion was.
But we should respect every person in spite of our unixes and differences.
And that's why, even in my own time, it was not difficult for me to embrace women preachers, though about 98% of black preachers who against white oppression have been against women.
My church, I have women preachers.
I have our day in the first woman preacher in this city, in this church, in 1984, where I women deacon, women involved throughout leadership team of this church.
And when the issue came up regarding gay rights, I had had a problem because I didn't knew what my teacher would do.
If he were here today, and I felt that it was wrong for us to codify one's rights, the rights of a people who have been marginalized, for they to deserve equal protection under the law.
Yet so many other churches didn't.
They did not, because they did not understand our king and they did not know how we got over.
You see John Mercer Langston back in 1866.
This is the John Mercer Langston, who was the first black to serve in Congress during reconstruction from Virginia.
And he and Charles Satchel, the first black pastor of Third Baptist, were in the leadership of the abolitionist movement in Ohio before 1850.
Back at my point, I have a copy of a speech that John Mercer Langston delivered in St. Louis, Missouri in 1866.
And you know what I tell you guys people? Equal protection before the law.
And he was fighting an organ for blacks to have the right to vote back then.
And he said among other things, if you feel that black folks must be educated, must be learned, know how to read and write, make sure that all white folks are required to do the same.
Because there are many of them who are in franchise who are voting.
That was something that really shook me away back then.
He was this man, a preacher and a lawyer who labored along with my predecessor, Charles Satchel, for equality of opportunity.
So I told all of my brothers who were not aware of this kind of history, were not aware of this kind of reasoning.
You know, you must not become that which you hate.
And if you hate, they're like the fact that white folks discriminated against you because of color your skin, don't discriminate against gay, lesbian, transgender.
And you're not going to be a white, a bisexual people because they're different.
And I pushed your eyes in that notion that we are all different.
As long as we're not violating the law during the injury harmed anyone, we should not legislate how people are to experience their own life, liberty and the pursuit of happiness.
And I tried to impact upon them the fact that, in principle, the rather, that I'm heterosexual.
That's who I am.
Gays and lesbians, transgender, bisexual people, that's who they are.
And we must not generalize on them.
And I remind them often that the divorce rate in America is the highest, not in California, not in New England, but the Unitarians are on the Liberals.
Not out here where they think we're cooking crazy, but the divorce rate in America is the highest in the Bible belt, where we sing the most, shout the most, preach the most, go to church the most.
And I always raise the relic of a question to them, how can you blame other people for not being able to keep your own relationship together?
I said, why is it that an Alabama, Mississippi, Georgia, Florida, Tennessee, South Carolina, North Carolina, up into Oklahoma.
The divorce rate in this nation is the highest amongst religious church-going people.
Can't explain it.
And then I remind them also, in terms of respect and the worth of the dignity of all people, the King James, who gave us the King James translation in the Bible, that many of them loved to hear.
These and the dolls, the old Chaucer in English, you know.
I said, did you know that King James was gay?
And I really had them there, and on which way to run.
I said, because he was gay and he made this contribution, are you going to burn up all the Bibles?"
I think we should be aware.
I said, now that does not mean that you are not entitled to decide what you're going to do about marriage equality, in context of your religious rights, RITES.
There's a difference between religious rights and the rights that we are guaranteed under Constitution and the laws of the state.
And I said, you cannot discriminate against people.
And I reminded them also, we would not be Baptist, if we did not have the freedom to interpret the Bible in the way that we are led to do because Roger Williams in 1638 was run out of the Massachusetts Bay Colony, because the Puritans and the congregation said, we're going to have a state church, we're going to tell people what to believe.
He said, oh no, I'm going to have freedom of conscience.
There'll be a separation of church and state, autonomy of the local congregation.
And I said, are you going to deny, are you going to spit on the principles that enable you to be a Baptist?
I said, we must not deny those persons, those congregations, the right to perform the same sex marriage, if they want to.
I said, that may not be a part of my tradition.
And I have that right as one living in a democratic society to follow the tradition that speaks to me.
And I said, I do not perform same sex marriage because of the tradition that I'm exposed to where I am here and now.
But it's wrong. It's not just, it does not provide equal protection on the law for you to go out and join with forces, whether it's Catholic church or the moment to say we're going to deny these persons equal protection on the law.
By imposing our private religious persuasions and doctrines on them.
It's a free country. It is not a theocracy. It is a democracy, a government, a people, and for the people.
And are those people, are gay and straight for people, black and white, brown, yellow, red, who are precious in God's sight.
And that's what I stood on. And many didn't want to hear it. Even some of this church, finally they came around.
And on Sunday morning, a young man who finally had to apologize to me in the whole church, tried to come up and take over the poor pit once on the morning.
When I said that I was not going to support proposition eight.
And right now, I believe in my own way to be in vindicated because I think the change has come.
Even the position that Mr. Obama, the president has taken.
Here again, I was the prophet as my son in school teacher told me to be, who bore the burdens of the people.
And I think that I have, I'm born those burdens, not just for black people, not just for women, but also for gay people.
You mentioned earlier the idea of, you mentioned earlier the idea of not only civil rights but human rights.
Yes, can you talk about that in the context of what?
Well, as a human rights, it takes us into the global picture.
I think we must see that in our Christian tradition at his best, the notion is there that Christ died for the world, not for America, but for the world.
And in that world, there are people of different cultures, different backgrounds, different religions.
So that I must be careful about my economics, my politics here at home, in terms of seeing how they impact people who are in Bangladesh, Central America,
South America, Africa, poor people.
You see, we're about 4% of the, one time we were six, but I made about 4% of the world population.
But we consumed 45 to 5% of the world's goods and resources.
And yet the Bible says, the earth is the lowest, the food and the world and they dwell therein.
So it's not fair for me to support industries that are paying these horrible wages for people in China.
These other calls, so-called Third World Nations, who are working cheap labor to support our standard of living.
What happens over in these countries does come back to impact us.
Dr. King also says, injustice anywhere, if everybody gets around the effect in all of us, everywhere.
And that's the reason why he wrote the letter from the Birmingham jail.
Remember the white clergy of Birmingham said, you don't need to be coming here stirring up trouble, you don't live here.
You don't pay taxes here. Get out of town, Dr. King. Stay in your own pool pit up there in Atlanta.
But he wrote that letter to let them know that we are in this garment mutually impacted.
And what affects one gets around the impact in us all throughout the world.
That's why we have to take this issue beyond just him civil rights for us in America.
And look at the human rights of all people on the face of the reserve.
And when you really go way, way back, get technical.
Real members of the same family, according to Leakey, the paleontologist, our first home was in Africa, in the Rift Valley.
And I tell many people, when we are unkind to people of different races, we are messing with our kinfolk.
And the only reason why we got these distinctives in terms of human features is because we migrated from one place to the other.
And we are adjusted to the environmental conditions.
But we must remember what my mother told me when I left home.
Amos behaved. Unfortunately, when we left our home in Africa, we failed to behave.
Wherever we established cultures and civilizations, we became arrogant and developed this dichotomy of them against us, against them.
Instead of getting that one little pronoun, we, we are family.
We are part of this world community. And we are going to share these resources and not be greedy and hoard unto us.
Over our fair share, other world's resources.
You know, if I'm having this in time of the use of these tapes, I put them on YouTube and stuff.
Can I just, I've found this extremely moving, but another thing that was very moving was seeing hearing you talk to the youth when we, when we were first here waiting.
Could you say something about what message you, what you're trying to convey to young people now in these times?
Well, this was a group of young men, students at Stanford, UC Berkeley, University of San Francisco, UCLA, who were pledging to be members of the Alpha Phi Alpha fraternity.
That's also the fraternity of Dr. King, my fraternity too.
W.E.B. Du Bois, and had a young Joseph Larrie and others.
Well, I was trying to impress upon them that in the spirit of Alpha, we would be men of scholarship,
man of deeds, and love for all humankind.
And this is what Dr. King epitomized.
First of all, he was scholar.
He entered more house at the age of 15, the early admission student.
Though at more house his average, and I have a copy of his transcript, he was a C plus student.
However, at more house, those professors were hard task masters.
When he finished more house, he went on to Crozer Theological Seminary, and he was a nays student, was president of the student body.
When on the Boston University, he got his Ph.D. degree. He was a scholar.
And that's the reason why I worked here in my ministry to clone, to create more young King scholars.
Right now, we're involved in a program over at Martin Luther King Middle School called Students of Promise,
Working with Latino and African American males who are under achieving.
You see the mean average for all black students at the middle of high school levels in this city, believe it or not, is D plus.
And only 30% of black students in this district finish.
30% finish high school.
And when you look at the higher education level, the same percentage obtained.
Of those who enter school, whatever reason, drop out, on about 34% finish.
That's tragic.
So I was trying to let these young men know, I repeat, that they have the responsibility that once they get their sheep skin,
don't forget that Mary McLeod Bethune said, when you become the first black here, the first black there, and first black there.
Make sure you are not the last one.
And as you climb up, reach back and pull someone along with you.
And I was challenging them to really work to be role models, or models for young men in inner city communities.
Secondly, I was appealing to them to be involved in the culture and the communities of the black people.
And when you're trying middle class blacks go unto themselves and forget about the community, about reminding them that they were needed now to be what the W.E.B. Du Bois call missionaries of culture and self-help.
And then thirdly, I was trying to remind them that they need to be world citizens, not be provincial.
The same as I was tutored and taught to do so through the experiences that I had with Operation Crossroads Africa when I first went to Africa in 1964.
The other thing that I did I mentioned earlier is that that program was started by a black, presbyteer pastor,
named James Robinson, who was pastor of the Church of the Master in Harlem in 1958.
Same year I got in trouble with that article in Cleveland playing dealer about conditions of education in Mississippi.
Dr. Robinson started this program.
I was talking about engaging American and African students in summer programs of studying, travel and community development programs.
This is where John Kennedy got the idea of the Peace Corps front.
And where did you go?
I went to Liberia, Sierra Leone, Senegal, and Ghana.
It's been two and a half months there on the West Coast of Africa.
That's my first exposure I repeat to Africa.
And I've been to Africa since then, 22 times all over.
And I was one of the founders along with Dr. Dr. Leon Howard Sullivan of that program called the African-American Summit.
The first summit was held in Côte d'Arre in Abidjan, Ivory Coast, about 90s, 91, who was.
And I never should have forget that night that we met in the home of Dr. Sullivan 1990.
And he shared with us this vision of pooling African-American leaders and scholars, business persons together to build relationships across their landing.
As I was always speaking, to really help Africa go to the next level in terms of development in areas of education, economic empowerment, and community development.
I went to many of the summits.
How influential do you think that first experience with Operation Crossroads Africa was for you and how you view the world in your career path?
Well, it gave me a practical experience, putting into action what I learned in 1958 at Camp D'Ambe of the Cornell University.
Tennyson's poem "Ulysses", when he said, I am a part of all that I have met.
We've become what we met.
Our environment, our exposure, does create for us.
Impressions, mirrors, Charles Horton Cooley, "looking-glass self" sociological theory.
Our young people need more reflections in the mirror of them doing, achieving, seeing their counterparts, doing, achieving.
Unfortunately, in the Minnesota community, we don't have enough of those models.
Crossroads was that exposure, that reflection that I began to put into action in later years with Dr. Sullivan.
And then, here recently in the 1970s, when there was a great Cornage and War going on in Ethiopia and Eritrea.
There were a lot of refugees from that country.
The United States government was not fair in terms of admitting African refugees here, even though 50% of the world's refugee population was on the continent of Africa.
Back then, the quarter for all of Africa was 790.
But for other countries, you tell me about a minimum of at least 10,000.
And later on, it must roomed into about 50,000 for Soviet immigrant Jewish immigrants, 125,000 for Cubans, another 45,000 Southeast Asians.
So our immigration department was not just in fair in terms of Africa.
And when they were challenged on it, they said, oh, we don't want to cause a brain drain on Africa.
But they didn't say that about India. They said about these other countries. They admitted them to the country.
So I was involved in that effort in this congregation through my leadership sponsored about 3,000 refugees from Africa and the Caribbean islands.
In fact, the first home or haven that they received, when other churches, even black churches wouldn't receive them from Ethiopia, Eritrea, it was my home.
My wife and I took them into our house and turned our family room into a room for refugees until we were able to get some funds to lease a two-flat Victorian house for blocks away from the church, for doors rather.
And then later, we turned into a resellement program.
So here again, because of the exposure, the World Affairs camp, crawls rose when they needed somebody to advocate for African refugees.
I was there and did what I could to work for their betterment and good.
And here recently, I happened to have been invited to the 50th anniversary of the Independence of Ghana.
And while I was there in a crawl on the last night of that celebration, just before Stevie Wonder came on stage to perform, there was a young kid who performed, who was 13 years old in as a keyboard.
And then he really got the house, as they say.
And after his rendition, I asked one of the ushers to point out the parents are the sponsor of this young man.
And I met his mentor.
And I told her, this young man needs to come to the United States and finish high school for somebody who that gifted needs to have greater exposure.
And she said, well, he has been on two of the groups and going to junior art school of music, people out of school of music.
And everybody heard him. They said, well, the question is, he's a genius.
They made all kinds of promises, she said.
But they didn't follow through to give him an opportunity to come to America.
I said, well, don't you worry.
Let me get back home, give me about a month or two months.
And we're going to work something out to get this young man here.
So I came back, went to the headmaster at the Stuart Hall High School, this upscale school, Catholic school here, and told him about this young man.
And I convinced him to give Kofi, Vagabee, a score is 80 percent scholarship.
And he maintained a steady average.
And he was two years ago, going on two years now.
After he finished Stuart Hall, admitted to Morehouse, he maintained a steady average there.
And he had the conservatory of music.
He never made under A or A plus.
He just mesmerized the teachers there.
And he has written himself, composed himself about nine symphonies, seven or eight synodos, two operas.
And, believe it or not, he's interested in going into medicine and not music as his major.
So here we have Out of Africa, a Mozart.
Another Albert Schweitzer, if you please.
Schweitzer was a master on Bach and medical missionary, the Africa.
And since I brought him here, made him a part of our family.
The dreamers, if you want to bow on children, we have been very pleased that he's been a blessing to himself and to others.
And it's shown that if a child is exposed to great things, and utilizes his and eight gifts,
there's no telling what that person can become.
And the Cove is a great testament to that.
He came here for the Christmas break, and he played one of Chopin's pieces.
And just, I mean, wreck the house.
No music.
He's got it.
And the ice music on the computer.
He's riding the wherever he is.
And the other thing is great.
He's well balanced.
Play soccer, basketball.
We never had one problem out of him.
The four years that he was in our home when he was in high school.
Same things down at Mojave.
So this is rewarding to just be of help.
And nothing back.
But his doctor maize often said to me at Mojave and many of the students.
But it haunts me that he said to me one day, Mr. Brown, I've had many breaks into my life.
Many awards and honors have come my way.
I didn't deserve it all.
He said, I can't pay those people back.
However, the least that I can do is just pass it on to somebody else.
So whatever I do is a matter.
It's an exercise of passing it on to show my gratitude to God and to others.
For what they did for me.
When I went to Mojave in 1959, I had only $87 in my pocket.
And the room and board back then cost about $895 there.
But I met friends along the way.
My home church sent them my money.
I stayed with Dr. (Benjamin E.) Mays in housework, chauffeur, worked for Dr. Rufus Clemmitt, president of Atlanta University.
His wife was from Mississippi.
Ms. Pearl Johnson Clement took a lacking to me.
I'm sure because I was from Mississippi.
But those people were kind to me.
Dr. Clement's house that I first laid eyes on Elemeroseville when she spoke for the graduation of Atlanta University back in the 60s.
And these experiences have come my way because I hung out with people who were great models.
And who were just a terrific inspiration for me and many young people.
And in many ways that began with your relationship with Medgar Evers.
Can I ask you about the loss of Medgar Evers and how you experienced that?
You know, at Morehouse, they often teased me because I was from Mississippi.
And they always reminded me that I was from a foreign country.
And they would say to me, at break time, well, they must have better go and apply for your visa to get back Mississippi because you're going back to a different country and you're going back down there.
And it was that summer of 1963 that I was in summer school.
I missed some maths because I was out in the student demonstration in Civil Rights Movement.
And I had to do these courses to make sure that I finished my work in 64.
And this brother from Alabama said to me, amos.
You better not go and apply for your visa this time.
You better stay here.
Those things are getting rough down in Mississippi. I was like, what are you talking about?
He said, I heard in the news this morning that a Civil Rights worker was killed in Jackson.
And when he said that I knew his record.
And I had just spoken with him a few days before asking me if I would come and work that summer again as I had done previous summers doing organizing and youth work.
But I told him that I passed because I wanted to finish school on time.
And I would catch him later, you know.
But I was not shocked because I realized how tense it was.
And he had this pre-ordination that something would happen.
And he was too vocal and people were rallying around the calls.
That was great protest with students from Tougaloo College, Jackson State.
And then the freedom riders were coming later and including myself.
The pre-wish summer in 1961, though I was not with the group that went to Montgomery.
I went on myself on my way to Jackson.
And did my protest.
And I joined up with him there.
And they had sent most of them up to parchment to the prison there.
And so when I got there, a Medgar Evers told me that since they had already gone to the parchment, me to stay and engage young people in protests or some of the public facilities there in Jackson.
And the one that we chose was the municipal park.
You couldn't sit on the same bench and look at the monkeys of the elephants together with whites.
And I was arrested at the Livingston Zoo along with several other members of the youth movement of an ACP.
And that same summer I was arrested because I insisted that a young doctor would not call my 85-year-old neighbor boy.
When I took him to the University of Mississippi Hospital.
And they knew who I was because I had already been involved in demonstrations including the Livingston and Freedom Rides.
And when Chief Ray came out that show, it was Amos brown again.
And the doctor told him that I had taken him on because he called my neighbor boy.
And not a man, I bought his name.
And they said, well what are we going to get him on now?
And one of his, who tells us that, well we're arresting him on using profane language in public.
And I spent two nights in jail.
Tell me, go bail me out.
And there's an article that ended up in the Pittsburgh Courier, which Mr. Evers said that all you have to do is open your mouth in Mississippi and it's profane.
And that is in that State Sobbinger Commission report.
So that was my connection with Mr. Evers during his final days.
And I really was touched by, I was at the funeral.
And I remember after the funeral was over, there was a march.
And we were marching about two or three abreast behind the body before we shipped up to Washington for burial at the Arlington.
And these whites were so inferior, in fact, that we were there in such large numbers with Niagara, Amazon, Roy Wilkins and others.
That these police officers were using billi-clubs, hitting children, women, horses, with galloping over the funeral.
Yes, at the funeral.
And you were just defenseless. You couldn't do anything, but you know, you raised a hand to do anything, they were struck you down.
But that was a horrifying experience that day, dang, in Jackson.
So I've kept in touch with Mrs. Evers. In fact, I saw two weeks ago in New York at the National Board meeting of the HACP.
I'm still a national board. And I will be speaking at this May on May 11th in Jackson for the Freedom Fund dinner of the Jackson branch and also for the commemorative service in Jackson.
I've been marching the 50th year of the assassination of Medgar Evers.
So was that a moment of despair for you or quickly translated into galvanizing you to carry forward?
I've never had these moments of despair. If anything, these D2s made me more determined to continue the fight.
And Mr. Evers would not want me to stop to be dejected, but to get up, move on.
And that's what we must do. For this problem of race in America, it's still with us.
And as one scholar going out west, race matters.
It really does. Still unfortunate. And we have built a nation over a ism that should not be who well know whatever is in your DNA.
Unless you accept treatment, a therapy, or change your lifestyle can cause your discomfort or your demise.
As in the same thing I'm playing as America in the sense that we don't come to deal with this issue of race.
We're going to destroy this nation.
And we ought to move to get over it. We ought to go through the therapeutic process.
President Bill Clinton tried to do it with his commission on race.
That Dr. John Hope Franklin was chair, but that commission was derailed.
He was going to talk about it. And even though we have Mr. Barack Obama, the first African American to be president, we're not in the post-racial society, you know.
It's still here. Occasion-point. Let me say this right so that I won't be here to be heartless, but I must state the facts.
Black youth and children have lived every day in a climate of violence.
It is more violent for an African-American male between 15 and 30.
That was also a soldier and there's a storm, the Persian Gulf, by an Afghanistan. I'll be it now.
At this church, I'm leading funerals, practically every month, sometimes.
For young African-American male. It's not happening in other communities.
And all as often as happens for us per capita.
However, we did not get that excited about this issue of guns until 20, unfortunately, babies who have been principal of white.
One was by ratio, the little Latino black girl, Anna Green.
There was on seeing a clip of her sitting at the piano for a little brother.
Because her parents said they wanted the world to remember her as she was a bright child with hope and possibilities.
And you know what that little girl was singing and her brother was playing?
Night one, Mr. Note.
Come, thou Almighty King. Help us, thy name, to sing.
Father, all glorious, all over all victorious.
Come and rank over us, ancient of days.
If we were to take the heart, the lyrics of that song, we would see that in this nation that should reign supreme, a universal spirit and practice.
That whether child is in violence, in new town, my town, or whatever town, we should show concern and show as great passion for all as we do for one.
And I think that, though new town, maybe with the tipping point, we have the occasion now to deal with this culture of violence in America.
I just got back from a meeting on Friday with the senior staff, the chief of staff, vice president Biden.
With Franklin Graham and Richard Land of the Southern Baptist Convention, who was over the public policy and social justice commission of the Southern Baptist.
That's the largest Protestant nomination in the nation.
Out of that meeting, it was the agreement that we're going to call faith leaders together at the White House.
Possibly around the time of the anniversary of the assassination of Dr. King, April 4th.
Evangelicals from the White community, traditional civil rights leaders, Black faith leaders, people of all faith communities, to pledge our support for this president as he seeks to come up with sensible,
measures to get us beyond this culture of violence.
And already we agreed upon universal background checks, expansion of the mental health programs, addressing the issue of the exposure of children to this cultural violence that's in these video games.
And many of these real violent movies that are coming out of Hollywood.
So I think that's the beginning point.
Even though we still have miles to go and more to do in promises to keep, to address the semi-automatic weapons.
But I feel that we're on our way.
Of course, we're ridiculous that we have 12,000 to 12,000 homicides a year in this country.
And other countries, you know, 30, 40, maybe 50.
We're violent culture.
And it should not be for all the power and all the money we have and all the greatness that we brag about.
I feel that we must check ourselves and raise the question, is this really America at its best?
And I hope that it's not a relations assumption that we got to arm ourselves to redo, re-enact the Civil War.
Remember, you look at the demographics, the states where they are talking about this, shouting about wanting to have their guns.
It's the old red states, the Confederacy.
And those who have been in the Idaho and Montana, those who left the South where they're commensurating with themselves up there.
And basically, it is Republicans who are pushing this agenda of having these guns.
Who will be referred to?
What, Boogeyman, are we fighting?
This ought to be one nation under God with liberty and justice for all.
And John Winthrop's 1630 "A Model of Christian Charity" sermon, Arbella, which he envisioned that city on the hill.
Remember, he pushed the notion that this was to be a community of mutual responsibility, mutual help, and that we should look out for each other and be an example to the world of how you can maintain a new and democratic society.
We must not fall fit that vision.
We can't fulfill it by being against each other.
We must not turn on each other. We must turn to each other and create a Dr. King envisioned a beloved community,
a community in which we would recognize and respect our differences, or won't put it under the have respect for each other.
And see that out of one comes many, and not the other way around, many created one.
We talk about making America the melting pot, but in a melting pot, the ingredients lose their distinctive, uniquenesses.
But in a solid bowl, a solid bowl, the entities, the ingredients are still visible, but it's more nutritious, but we're told that a salad can be more nutritious than just eating meat or a pot of stew.
And I think that America would be healthier when we become one nation, but in our oneness, see that there are many strides, many cultures, and to be a multicultural mother-adding nation, that means that we are deficient.
It means that we are more in risk.
And when we're in risk, we're even safe. I'm black and I'm proud. I'm yellow and I'm yellow.
I'm red, but I ain't dead. I'm brown and I'm sound. I'm white and I'm alright.
I am gay, but I'm gotten it. I'm straight, but I'm sensible.
That's the kind of antifinal, united course that ought to be coming from America and not this dentist dissonance of hate, of division, and instruction of human life.
Thank you. I think we can put a line in the back.
Yeah, I think so too, and I'm tempted to just stand there so beautiful.
I would hope that as we tell this story of the movement, that there will be a support system and resources provided for a treatment of the many, many unsung heroes and she-ros.
Her name has never got into the paper, but who worked in the heat of the day, who went through a great challenge, hardship, and tragic moments.
Case in point in Mississippi, Mr. C. C. Bryant, a railroad man in McComb, Mississippi, was a great warrior, peaceful warrior.
Doc Owens, also in McComb, Mississippi. Amzie Moore in Clarksdale.
Mary Piggy's, Dr. B. E. Murph. Samuel Bailey. Joseph Broadwater.
Carsey Hall. Randolph Darden from Meridian.
J. A. Newell. Rev. William Albert Bender, who really laid the groundwork for the student movement and the civil rights movement in Mississippi in the 50s.
Back in 1946, Reverend Bender, who was college pastor at Tougaloo College, their congregational-related school, wrote letters to Walter White,
and his radical letters on file, about his efforts to get equal pay for black teachers in Mississippi.
And he also fought the white primaries in Mississippi. This is before Fannie Lou Hamer in Atlantic City.
This man, who was courageous, he walked all over Jackson, everywhere he went, where he was rain, shine, sleet of snow, he had an umbrella on his arm.
And here again, goes back to this thing of exposure in terms of what it does to make us who we are. His daughter, Lou Ella Bender, was one of the persons who was in that car with me in 1956.
And Miss Deva, and Miss Deva Irvin, who was the advisor to the Grambling, College, college chapter in Grahamland, Louisiana.
When we came West in 1956, we left Jackson and went to Grambling and picked her up, and we came out here together.
Well, it was her father, who pioneered, he was a pioneer in Mississippi, another preacher, who was a new breed, who even many times walked alone.
And there also was Gladys Bates, who filed the first suit, and along with a husband, John Bates, and her father, Mr. Norris, was another champion.
You see, the people who were in the band got a movement were independent because they worked for the U.S. government, as postal workers,
are they what, and showing sales persons, and Ella Bates, who had depend on whites for their livelihood, and done in immediately.
Barbara Schaup, yes, Fieneroll, yes, Fieneroll, yes, that's right.
And another person was Rev. R.L.T. Smith, who was one of the first blacks to run for Congress.
He lived right down the street from my home house. He owned a grocery store, and was a leather carrier.
Reverend LC Wilcher, he also came to this meeting in 1956, in San Francisco, National Convention.
He was a leather carrier. Car say haul, the attorney that I mentioned earlier was a leather carrier.
John W. Dixon was a leather carrier.
So you see many segregationist of South, talk about maintaining their state's rights, because they knew that they could do whatever they wanted to do to do blacks in, and to oppress black people and keep them down.
And when they talk about, we don't want the government interfering. What government are they talking about?
The U.S. government, the federal government, and it's another coded message of being against blacks.
When they say we got to protect ourselves against the tyranny of the government, when they were referring to the government, it's not about that state government.
Not about the state government of Mississippi, like South Carolina where they still want to force the Confederate flag.
They're talking about the federal government, because they don't want to do right.
They don't want equal protection of the law, and they don't want justice for everybody.
They want to maintain their old southern way of life.
I asked you a question. I saw an article that came out with Trudeau that argued with a lot of citations and quotations from the Constitutional Convention.
The Second Amendment was in the Constitution because they were protecting the padderholes and the southern militias that kept on slaves suppressed.
It was a revelation to me. I don't think you could argue that.
Definitely. They needed these guns to go after us.
They needed even Abraham Lincoln mentioned. That was a book. You know the fellow up at Columbia, Andrew, Andrew Delbanco.
Usually it's called the real American dream, meditations of hope.
And he cites how even President Lincoln mentions how blacks were hounded and how we were kept from escaping the courts of slavery because of weapons.
The weapons and the bounty hunters go back to your point.
And that's what came out in that movie, Django.
All right.
Okay. Okay.
Thank you so much.
Let me run down here.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.